welcome to exploring computing
today's video is digital music
part two from analog to digital so in
the last lecture we saw that
music is really a sound wave and that we
can actually take a look and see what
that wave looks like
what we need to do now is figure out how
we can take that wave and start using
the bits and bytes that we saw
in the previous lecture so let's take a
closer look at that wave right now
and make sure we understand what's going
on here so here's a
very close-up view of part of the wave
from beethoven's fifth symphony
and moving along the x-axis this is an
increase in time so as time goes on
we're seeing the magnitude of the wave
at different points in time so in order
to store this information into our
computer what we need to do is we need
to
take measurements at specific points in
time and what we're going to do is we're
going to store a sequence of numbers
corresponding to the height of the wave
at different points
now one of the decisions we need to make
when we're doing this is how often to
take
samples and this is referred to as a
sampling rate
okay so what we're seeing here is the
original sound wave
with some samples taken the black
vertical bars represent
specific times that i'm taking samples
the red line represents
the line using the samples that i've
taken you'll notice that the red line
does not
follow the original light gray line the
light gray line is the original sound
wave
if we were to take an infinite number of
samples then our
red line would match the gray original
line but we can't take an infinite
amount of samples that would take
an infinite amount of storage so what's
happening here is
we're taking specific points along the
line and we're attempting to reproduce
the original sound wave using the
samples we've taken
let's watch what happens if we reduce
the sampling rate this next image shows
a reduced sampling rate again we're
seeing samples taken over time but we're
seeing a lot fewer samples taken
and you'll notice that the red line is
starting to diverge
pretty far from the original gray line
this new wave does not look that much
like the original wave and one of the
problems is
because we haven't taken samples
frequently enough our samples have
completely missed some of the peaks and
valleys of the original signal
the other thing we have control over is
what our measurements look like
along the y-axis this controls our
dynamic range
and what we can do is we can change
what's referred to as the bit depth
which is the number of bits we're
setting aside to represent
numbers along the y-axis here's two
examples here
in this first example i'm storing
numbers between
plus 8 and negative eight and in the
second example i'm storing numbers from
plus two to negative two
now if you look at these carefully and
you think back to the previous lectures
you'll realize that these are slightly
off it really should go from
plus seven to negative eight and plus 1
to negative 2 in order to actually match
the number of bits but i thought that
would make the problem even more
confusing so we're going to go ahead and
stick to an even number of
positive numbers and negative numbers
just to keep the example simple
all right so let's take a look at the
plus 8 to minus eight example first
and you can see that i'm taking a number
of samples
so the thing to remember here is i'm
setting aside a given number of bits so
i can't store an infinite number of
possible values
i can't store o the height of the wave
at this point is
7.2562 i need to store it
in the number of bits i've been given so
in this example i'm assuming i can store
integer values from positive 8 to
negative 8 and that is it
and so you can see i'm attempting to
follow the original gray line
but i'm limited to being able to store
values along these specific discrete
integer values
now let's take a look at the other
example where i'm only able to store
values between negative two and positive
and you can immediately see that this
next example is not going particularly
well
so what's happening here is the greater
the bit depth
the more accurately i'm able to
represent the wave so we've seen we can
control the sampling rate which is the
number of samples taken
over time and we can control the bit
depth which helps determine the dynamic
range
and that tells us what particular values
we can store at each of the sample
points
so it may be obvious that the more
samples we take
the better and the wider our bit depth
the better and so the question is why
don't we just use huge values for each
of these the answer is of course that
the higher the sampling rate is and the
greater the bit depth is
the more space our music is going to
take so here's the standard that cds use
44 100 samples per second often
just written as 44.1 kilohertz 16 bits
per sample and two channels a left and a
right channel
dvds use something very similar in terms
of the same bit depth and very similar
numbers of samples per second
blu-rays can actually have an increased
number of bits per sample
but this is essentially what most of us
are listening to but we're not really
quite done yet because it turns out
there's an extra step that occurs
before most of the music that you listen
to actually
gets on your computer and that's because
this specification is for an actual
physical cd disk and i'm guessing
almost none of you actually buy cds so
in the next video we're going to see
what this extra step looks like and why
it's there